the New York Times reports on a lawsuit  claiming a California hospital secretly  recorded women during surgery and listen  to this  childbirth oh no a lawyer for the woman  says 1800 patients may have been filmed  at sharp Grossmont hospital in La Mesa  sharp healthcare says it installed  cameras to investigate medication theft  in 2012 and 2013 and did not use them  again it says that it sincerely regrets  any distress that it caused to patients  I think any woman who's recorded during  childbirth without her permission that  is a really really really serious and  offensive yeah action to me because  nobody looks cute during childbirth and  it's painful and you make a lot of  really uh even like noises yes let me be  your doula and get you through this  moment measuring my teeth the powder job  enough setting